and even if it is a more competitive
series in game one
this is why i'm already going back on my
pick
it's because how how locked in and we've
been talking about it you and i have
been talking about it we talked about it
with chris hayne talked about it with
any goodwill how
locked in lebron is right now lebron's
lebron's on some cobra car right now
lebron's on some sweep the leg okay he's
also sweep the leg stuff right now
and speaking of snakes
the mamba mentality yeah that we know he
had already adopted and possesses in his
own right
coupled with a killer instinct you know
one of the things i can't stand
is when people when they try to compare
lebron to kobe
or michael jordan for the longest time
and even now they still and we'll talk
about kyrie stuff later on
that that's c word right but for the
longest time man
people would talk about like oh he's not
a killer you know lebron ain't a killer
like mike lebron's not a killer i'd be
damned
i'd be damn him on the killer instinct
he out here killing all the fun
end of the game lakers celebrating
enjoying it he like now settle down
settle down this ain't over and i love
after the game
gary do we have that side or nah we have
that song look at that
fancy words fancy word what tell the
people all right
check out what looks like this is this
is in the back of lebron's mind
when he's telling everybody hey it's not
over stop celebrating
job ain't done this with the back of
lebron's mind roll it
the best teacher in life is experienced
and i've experienced moments in my
career
finals games where you had all the
momentum in the world
and you felt like you had the game under
control one play here or one play there
could change the course of a series or
change the course of a game
and um one in particular that always
rings home for me um
it's game two uh the 2011 finals
in miami vs dallas um d wade hits a
three
right by that bench uh i believe put us
up
either 13 or 17. and from that moment on
dallas went on a hell of a run and
finished it off with a dirk new whiskey
left hand layup
to steal that game that reminds me
to this day uh to quote about that queen
stephanie mills
experience is a good teacher and it
takes someone like me to know
that is stephanie mills right i'm in
love with the new management i mean
this the lebron is not playing games
right now
and no matter how many people think that
he's the favorite
no matter how many people think that
this should be a short series and that
that the heat are just some scrappy
underdogs and the lakers are top heavy
the two best players
he's like i remember
feeling like we had a series under
control only for it to devolve
into one of the darkest chapters if not
the the low point of his career
right his personal collapse against uh
dallas so man i'm looking at that
combined with the injuries
combined with the anthony davis lebron
james tandem
and i'm saying all right man um you know
cancel christmas it was it was fun miami
it was a fun ride miami but
the king ain't letting this you said it
you told me you told me he was not about
to let this happen no way he was not
not gonna say he can't lose somebody
cannot he cannot he cannot lose he will
not lose the series by the way
uh boys and girls assad is
sound on tape it's an old school term
really
it's old school because it's not too
don't even use tape anymore yeah
but you know we just like we just like
to tell you all the tv terms
uh here's the other thing mike how about
that memory he's like nine years ago you
know 2011.
so you know d-wade hits a shot going to
that bench
to put us up i think it actually put
about 15 and then
to make it even worse wade makes the
shot and says
it's over he said that to their bench
which anthony davis did last night i
don't know if anthony was talking about
he was running on a series but he miled
it last night
you know he was right no but i just
think uh
we're talking about these matchups all
right how about the lebron match-up
okay let's just let's just talk about
that
matching up with anthony davis is one
thing
so i know miami is really going to
struggle with that like all their big
men
you can so you gotta hurt a hurt bam so
he's probably out
you know kelly olynyk like who who do
you really have
who do you really have just gonna
challenge
yeah anthony davis so you know
we know you messed up there but this
version of lebron this
this guy who is willing to okay i'll get
my points eventually i'm trying to get
you guys going here
i'm gonna get my assist game going i'm
gonna get my board game
going and then late in the game i'm
gonna i'm gonna put in my points
yeah it's amazing yeah i i yeah i told
you it's uh
i may have told you the story uh years
ago
i was doing a book with uh terry
francona the former manager of the red
sox
and as you guys know he was michael
jordan's
minor league manager in birmingham with
the birmingham barons
he said just to blow his mind sitting
there talking basketball with jordan he
was like hey you know jordan
why'd you retire man like what's going
on he was like yeah you know
i can go back to basketball i mean look
i it really comes down to this that's
what he's what he told frank kona
it really comes out of this man i get my
eight points a quarter
and that's 32. yeah eight eight eight
eight yeah
anytime i want yeah i mean hey don't
make it sound so
easy but it is easy it was easy for
people like that it is
and it's easy for lebron too but i just
want to say this i've been thinking
about this all week and i'm glad you
mentioned it up this whole
killer instinct uh for lebron the mental
toughness for lebron
i think it's so easy for us to forget
that michael jordan watching the last
dance remember when jordan was there in
a hotel room he's like
you know when this is over i'm good i
i've had enough
i don't need to deal with this i can't
leave my room i can't do this
i got so much and i i don't really my
life is not my own essentially
but that was in 19 what 1998 that was in
1998
so there was uh no facebook
there was no tmz there was no twitter
you barely had people didn't know how to
then people still didn't know how to
work the internet
i know newspaper journalists didn't yeah
they were late to that party
so no look imagine lebron
to to be in the public eye since you
were a
teenager to come into the league with
expectations
not only to meet the expectations but to
exceed them
you don't think that's did you get some
credit for that
isn't that a a degree of mental
toughness
so i think i think that's over i think
that's so overstated when it comes to
lebron and i do want to say this
uh before we move i'm not gloating yet i
will go soon
i'll probably go i'm not ready to move
though make this point but i'm not ready
to move though go ahead
all right no i'm not gonna make a turn
i'm gonna give you a bounce pass right
back to you
bounce pass back to you guys my point is
a turning point
okay well i want to stay on the
experience you know is the best teacher
because i
personally relate to that in many
respects especially over the last couple
of years
like i was like lebron the thing i like
about not just lebron but a lot of these
press conference but specifically lebron
and
the mentality when you listen to lebron
and even go back and listen to kobe and
some of the
the philosophy that they're dropping
whether you're picking it up or not
they're dropping philosophy in in their
press conferences
think about let's stop and recognize
that the moment
that and at the time
you know felt like was going to ruin
lebron or break lebron
melting down against the mavericks
actually made lebron
you know like even just for me
personally in the last couple of years
you know trying to trying to navigate
even my career my personal journey and
being like well
why is this happening or why am i going
through this so why am i dealing with
that or
okay this is the next move wait a second
i know that's not the next move it's
another move and
okay now i'm on now i'm on start-up
number three you know what i mean
oh okay so all that happened to get me
here everything that happened
was to get me here you know i know my
steps are ordered but man
like oh okay this is this is to this is
to to mold me and craft me and educate
me and
and get my mind and my my spirit to a
place
for to prepare me for the for this for
the rest of this journey right
and so for lebron it's like oh wait a
second all right
so he looks awful against
miami the moment's too big for him or so
we thought
comes up small in the finals we know
that he went on to win the next two
we know that he went on to deliver one
to cleveland
looks like he's about to deliver one to
la and in this moment he's saying
that experience had prepared me to do
what i'm about to do
we may not have this lebron he may not
be the killer that he is right now if he
hadn't gotten wounded
in 2011. you know and i think about just
all all experience is good experience
somebody told me all experience is a
good experience so even if you're going
through something right now that just
feel like you're in the valley it's like
there are no mountaintops without
valleys
you know and so like you know can i
turn to your neighbor and say there are
no mountaintops in our valley
tell us tell
[Laughter]
honestly i was i was moved by that i was
moved by that because i'm like damn i
feel that because
that was his low point but it prepared
him for this
and and who knows what more yeah that's
good mike and
i think i think you're right i mean it's
dallas
it's the it's the bad fourth quarter
it's really like a
it's probably like three parts of three
different
seasons or three episodes if you look at
lebron
like three distinct episodes before we
get to that finals
it's the decision right it's the
criticism from that
it's the first time in his career you
know seven years into his career it's
almost like hey lebron james oh
he's so great he's amazing all this
stuff and then it's the first
profound sustained criticism
of his career now that sounds that
sounds okay that's not really a big deal
a lot of professional athletes haven't
gone through that
at a sustained level at a high level the
high level athlete
is so used to the adoration but to have
a nation
against you outside of miami for an
entire year
okay yeah that that'll change your
perspective
the decision as you pointed out the
fourth quarters
against the mavericks the lost to the
mavericks
and then and we talked about this before
remember
down three two to the side
yeah before that first championship
before that first so now down 3-2
and it seems like ancient history but
people were oh
people were dancing you want to do some
church you were you you going church on
this
we had praise dances going on people
were hiking up
hiking it up going around because miami
was about to like about to fall on his
face
to the celtics and they're go and go in
the boston garden lebron
scorches them so no jordan
yep and that and that led to the first
first of two championships
so jordan said the shot in 82 against
boston and i know we got to go to break
here but jordan said
the shot 82 not against boston sorry
against uh georgetown georgetown
that propelled him moving forward like
oh once i made that
one i knew i could always go back to
that even if i missed i could always go
back to that moment where i made it to
give me the confidence to take those
shots
but then kobe mentioned him kobe talked
about utah
kobe isn't kobe without experiencing
that quote-unquote failure
against utah that he built on that um
so yo uh do you want to make that quick
point that i stopped you from or you
want to take this break because we gotta
come
listen listen listen rev you you gave us
some good preaching
and so no i'm just kind of runs in the
face
reverend smith you touched my soul so
you got sense enough not to preach after
the past is finished
nothing bothers me more there was
usually it's the pastor that's guilty of
it the guest preacher will preach and in
the past you've got to give them give a
sermon like dog
let that live just let me do that and
just
do the better dictionaries go home they
say you know after this i'm going to
take my seat and then like 20 minutes
later you know as i
as i go to my seat man you said that as
i close
[Laughter]
no as i hurry to close as i heard
you